a to manifold is a thin piece of surface
like this piece of paper or this piece
of thin plastic but a to manifold must
not have any branches a book that has
many pages but has a spine where they
all come together that would not qualify
as a two manifold but even a weird thing
like that would qualify as a two
manifold two manifold may have borders
such as this Mobius band or it may have
holes like this particular Klein bottle
or it may be completely closed like this
surface of an eco Saheed run or the
shell of an egg now for topologists all
objects are made of infinitely
stretchable rubber and so the geometry
aliy doesn't matter and if I deform this
Mobius band you know it stays the most
dis band and the topologist would still
classify this in exactly the same way as
the original shape from this point of
view all of these two manifolds can be
classified by just three integer numbers
the first one is the number of borders
this particular Mobius band has just a
single border I can run my finger around
the border here and if I go around the
loop twice I'm coming back to where I
started so this is not the edge this is
the edge of the thin surface this
particular plastic piece has two borders
you know one is a circular here and the
other one is this particular edge here
so this is the path where as an ant was
crawling on it would cast seven that's
right and if we look at this piece of
paper this one has three borders one is
the rectangle frame on the outside and
then we have you know a circular border
here and suffer kidney shape border over
on this particular case so this is the
first number the second number is the
sidedness of a surface so this piece of
paper is clearly two-sided as a matter
of fact it has a blue side and it has a
white side and you cannot get from one
side to the other without crawling over
this very sharp edge where an ant would
copy itself to death the Mobius band on
the other hand has a single side if you
start
painting and spreading your paint
without ever crossing one of the edges
you would come around and you would note
this that by the time you're done you
have actually painted both sides of this
particular surface so that's a single
sided surface with a single edge on the
other hand the Klein bottle here is also
single sided surface but as you can see
it has no edges however we cannot really
create a completely closed Klein bottle
in three-dimensional space without
having either some opening some
punctures or a self-intersection line
and you can see here here is one of
those self-intersection lines now if I
don't like these self-intersection lines
I could cut a slightly larger hole into
the wall of the thick arm so that the
thin arm then can be passing through so
in this model rather than living with
the self intersection I have cut a large
enough opening into the green body so I
can bring out the thin arm without
creating a self intersections but for
the price of creating an opening a
so-called puncture which has its own
border so this would still be a client
bottle but now it is a client bottle
this one puncture there's an important
message here and that means that simple
holes that you cut in a surface do not
change the type of surface for a
topologist even though this little thing
has a whole lot of little holes it would
still be considered a client bottle but
with many many many many many punctures
now from that point of view this little
cylinder is really just a sphere with
two punctures and this becomes a little
bit more obvious if you try to cap off
these openings so we put a cap on here
now it would be a sphere is only one
puncture and by the time I'm adding the
second cap it becomes of more obvious
that this is topologically just a sphere
there is a third number that is
important for the classification of all
too many folds and that has to do with
the connectivity of the surface it's
called the genus of a surface a sphere
or equivalent topological shapes would
be
of genus zero a donut would be a genus
one at two whole doughnut would be a
genus 2 and here is a more complicated
object and the surface of that would
also be a two manifold of genus 2 the
genus is clearly related to how many
holes you have in your doughnut
or how many handles that there are a
more precise definition would be how
many closed loop lines can you draw on
that surface that if you were to cut
along them the surface would still hang
together if I take my piece of paper cut
a circle loop into it then the inner
part of that hole falls out and is
clearly no longer connected on the other
hand if I take my simple torus and I cut
along this red line then I simply get
some kind of you know tubing but it
still all hangs together so this is of
genus one because I draw one such line
if I had a two hole tourists I could
draw two such lines and I can cut along
those and after both those cuts the
surface still all hangs together so
that's a surface of genus 2 if I take my
Mobius band and I'm cutting along that
red line I maintain that this Mobius
band will not fall apart now what do I
get I get a loop twice the size it has a
twist of 360 degrees in it but it is
still in one piece and since I could do
one such cut that means that Mobius band
had the genus of one try to cut it again
in the middle then it actually would
fall apart there's only one way of
cutting the Mobius band along a line and
then we're done to see whether it's not
perhaps genus 2 here
now I've to individual pieces and I
cannot get from one piece to the other
so the surface is no longer connected so
clearly Mobius band is only genus one
the climb bottle is actually of genus
two and I've tried to indicate that by
drawing two such lines which I could cut
along the red line on one side and the
green line on the other side and if I
did that the surface would still be
hanging together
so the Klein bottle is a single sided
surface there's no borders and it is of
genus 2 now I would like to make better
Klein bottles of a higher genus now how
could we do that I would like to build
these super Klein bottles in some
modular way the first possible way of
making a module is what I'm showing here
essentially taking the top half of the
classical Klein bottle that has the
important mouth the way it is this is
still a two sided surface to make that
clear I essentially painted the inside
here in silver so the inside of this
green toroidal body is silvery and then
it is being brought out here in this
silvery stem which by itself on the
inside is still green I want to use two
of these modules to make my super Klein
bottle and I'm contemplating on
essentially bringing together into a
ring and the neat these curved
connectors but you can see if I try to
put them together like that then silver
meets silver in the upper branch and
green meets green in the lower branch
and so I never really stepped from green
to silver and so that cannot possibly be
a single sided surface it's a perfectly
good you know two-sided surface ah but
what if I turn this thing around so
maybe I want to connect it like that let
me actually try to do that some assembly
required so now I have created this
contraption and it looks good you know
I'm getting from green to silver over
this branch but then wait if I go
through lower branch I get once more a
green silver
and that means I have an even number of
changes between the two surfaces and so
I'm not really getting a net
single-sided surface so again it's
two-sided that's disappointing maybe we
can put three of those into a loop so
here you can see a loop of three of
those client bottles we have three
transitions clearly it's an odd number
of transitions between the surfaces so
the whole thing is single sided but if
we analyze it in details we find that a
genus is still only two so there's
really nothing new over the ordinary
Klein bottles so maybe these should make
something more complicated what do we
need to do in order to get a super Klein
bottle of higher genus you know nothing
seems to reliever well in order to get
this done right we need to do what
mathematicians call a connected sum of
two or more klein bottles you start with
two ordinary Klein bottles and then you
cut the puncture in each one of them you
connect those two openings these an
umbilical cord and now if we do that we
actually get a single sided surface of
genus 4 here is my simple Klein bottle
but now I have added this branch with a
puncture and here is another client
bottle there's a puncture and if I put
the two together now I have what I call
the first super bottle which is a
surface of genus for the crucial thing
was to create this extra branch here
that allows me to have this component
coupled into another component and this
is a modular component that now allows
me to make higher genius klein bottles
or what I call super bottles so truly
now this is a single sided surface of
genus for these two punctures because
that's what I need if I want to see this
thing in three-dimensional space but in
four dimensions this would work in four
dimension I could do it without those
self intersections but here is a more
compact version of one of those genus
for single sided surfaces for clearly
many possible ways of creating such a
branching klein bottle module and I want
it to be this as general as possible to
make many different sculptures and so I
have chosen to use this particular
version which has the three arms come
out in
three mutually orthogonal directions by
doing that I can then put eight of those
around the corners of a cube frame but
even this special cube corner component
can be done in quite a few different
ways this is one of my first modules
then I have made another module and here
here the third module and they all have
one thing in common the ends of the arms
come out in three mutually perpendicular
directions and they all have the same
distance from the end of the arm to the
center of the three intersection lines
so they all can replace one another and
I put them in arbitrary ways around the
corners of a cube to make a modular
super bottle based on a cube frame
they're quite different but they're so
similar in style I have made sure all of
them rely essentially on one toroidal
body somehow that makes them belong to
the same family but in some instances
you can see here I'm branching out the
thick part where in this case I'm
feeding out the thinner tube and then
the thinner tube is the one that
branches into and in the third module
the thin of two branches into but the
actual branching occurs on the inside of
the module each one of these different
modules can go in different places and
each one of them can be rotated in three
different positions a few additional
curved elements I can make different
shapes for instance a three-sided prism
this is a version very have a fairly
regular prism by adding three pieces of
curved branches that each one turn
through 30 degrees here is a different
version ver rather than having three
inserted pieces I have two pieces of 45
degrees to make this you know somewhat
less regular triangle and then they just
copy two of these triangles behind one
another and I get something that looks
at three-sided prism another option is
curve shatter of 339 degrees and then in
this I can use four of my modules and
six of those bent pieces and I get
something that emulates a tetrahedral
frame a super bottle of Jena six Marez
this here was a super bottle of genius
eight of
once I had all these parts lying around
I was just playing and here are a few
more fancy shapes that are much less
regular so the inventiveness now has no
limits if it's enough parts lying around
if we introduce a new client bottle
module that actually has a four-way
branch then 1/4 of a branch gives us the
same increase in connectivity that we
would get from two 3-way branches these
only six of those four varieties I can
make a super bottle of genus 14 well
it's genius for time I also did
something a little bit special in one of
these branches
I pulled the inside of the toroid out
into this funnel shape thing so it can
serve as a stand of this particular
sculpture but that's still the stand is
part of the topology that you haven't
like broken the stand would simply be
one more puncture that this particular
module has and as we saw before adding
punctures does not change the genius of
a surface the classification would not
change because of that this is one that
uses five of those parts and here's
another one that uses six of those parts
but of course we can also combine the
three armed modules and the forearm
modules if I combine eight of my three
by parts raise six of my four-way parts
I get this what I would almost call a
super-duper bottle and this one now is
of Gina's 22 and this is based on the
frame of a rhombic dodecahedron what if
I want a single sided surface of genus 7
the key thing is to start with a Mobius
band as a building block because the
Mobius band has only genus of one so as
you add Mobius bands together you can
increment the genus one by one so here
is an Mobius band of a quite different
shape and I would have to cut some hole
in it in order to be able to graft it on
to something else
now here's a component where I have
already done that here again you see
almost the same shape in a Mobius band
but then here at the bottom here is the
hole that we're using now for grafting
two of those components and graph
on to one another I have added gene is
one plus gene is one that's gene is two
and so you should know what that is if
you've seen some of the other videos on
Klein bottles you know to mobius bands
together make a klein bottle of genus
two now to get to even higher genus
Hadiya lose a third component i would
have to graft a third component onto
this combination and then I would have a
single sided surface of genus three now
if you know that you want to make genus
seven what you need to do is find the
sphere drill seven holes into it and
then simply graft one of these punctured
mobile strips on each one of the seven
holes and voila
you get yourself a change of seven
single sided surface and this works for
any positive integer number
what are you doing for breakfast
something sort of Swiss Oh
seven or eight Klein bottles breakfast
you know like bagels you know this Klein
bottle oh so much tastier well they take
it HS fast because he digests from the
inside and from the outside